I came from a kind of quasi black
nationalist background writers have to
be exposed to the world okay like you
can't it's a you cannot limit yourself
to just black folks you clearly that
can't be because you'll only be as good
as what you're around it's like a a
businessman who says I'm only gonna go
into a certain market it ignores all
other markets much to his peril so there
were two strains of thoughts going on
going into my life my household there's
a sort of quasi black nationalist thing
I say quasi because I don't want to take
away my dad's on originality we didn't
spend to celebrate Kwanzaa but that
hated Kwan's just wait for people who
came up like us but at the same time my
dad was always kind of in an iconoclast
never objected to us playing Dungeons
and Dragons or anything like that
encouraged that encouraged imagination
encouraged exploration that was probably
the primary value even more than
whatever a particularly cultural ethnic
outlook I took out of my house
the idea of exploration and imagination
was huge and it probably was the biggest
thing that I took out of my house so
when I went out into the world that
gelled a messed really well with the
idea of being a writer and it quickly
became apparent that if you're going to
be a writer you have to not really have
limits you can't be afraid to go
anywhere and that's really what it is at
the end of the day when we restrict
ourselves this fear you're not going I'm
not going over there with them white
folks I'm you know what I mean like we
talked about it in a bad way but really
is it you're scared you're afraid that
really is what the deal is in terms of
what's going on you can't be afraid if
you're gonna go out here and compete in
any in any sort of real way so I I had
to separate would have a political
ambitions I had and commit to something
and once I decided I really really
wanted to be a writer there wasn't much
room like I have my political
sensibilities but when I'm writing a
story I don't think about it from that
perspective
if I want to tell a beautiful story I
want people to read it and love the
narrative I'm not necessarily interested
in making people into left liberals like
me you know that's what I am I don't
write to convert people I write to tell
stories that's the first thing that's
the primary thing for me everything
after that I mean if you convert over to
my side of politics great beautiful but
all the great works of art that I've
ever seen that had any sort of political
import well always great stories first
they were great stories before anything
I think ideology kills art I think it
kills writing all the time think it just
completely completely destroys it so I
really had to make a choice and my
choice was to tell stories and once I
decided it out that was what I was going
to do the whole idea of being an
activist was pretty much shunted aside
anything like that that was gonna happen
was gonna be because somebody was
inspired by something I think back to
like Zora Neale Hurston who in the 20s
and into the thirties wanted to write
stories about how African Americans were
as they actually lived
scorn was heaped upon her because she
wasn't interested in writing about
lynching for instance she wasn't
interested in writing about how
segregation warped black people that was
what Richard Wright was trying to do his
idea was to write in such a way as to
affect political change
I read native son in college and I hated
native son a terrible book this is an
awful story like the story isn't good I
don't you know I'm not interested in how
he was trying to show the effects of
racism if I don't enjoy the book I don't
care I was a day uh
Their Eyes Were Watching God God I've
read that and I thought wow this is
beautiful writings I don't know how this
beautiful this is what I want to do I
want to do something like this I'm not
particularly interested I mean pardon
you know my rudeness here I'm not I just
was not interested in changing the minds
of white folks I mean I wasn't who I
wanted to be and I guess I wasn't later
I wasn't personally interested in
changing the amount of black folks
either
I just wanted to write a beautiful story
and I thought the truth would emerge did
the universal values would emerge from
telling the story